cette rose a une histoire toute
particulière avec la réunion elle
s'était close pour la première fois dans
un parterre de nos jardins créoles et
porte le nom scientifique de rosa
bourgogne anna ou plus communément
rosburg elle n'est certes pas une espèce
endémique de la réunion mais elle est
unique car issu d'une hybridation
naturel entre deux variétés de rosiers
des parents qui sont très intéressants
par un des parents c'est une rose de
chine
d'accord qui s'appelle aux boeufs et une
autre c'est une rose de damas aux à
damas damascena saint pée florence alors
leur sit in ils apportent caractère
remontant remonta c'est à dire que la
rosselle refleurit tout le temps
d'accord c'est un caractère très
intéressant tandis que les réussites
damas ils ont affronté un autre
caractère c'est le quartier le parfum
notamment donc c'est ce qui fait que
cette rose da elle est très parfumé et
en même temps que l'existant et elle
referait tout le temps découverte en
1817 à bourbon sur la propriété d'edward
perrichon à sainte suzanne
cette rose de bourbon tend à disparaître
au profit de variétés plus moderne
voilà pourquoi l'association jardins
créoles et le département lance une
campagne de sensibilisation envers la
population afin d'initier un inventaire
de cette rose reine de nos jardins
créoles ans nous faisons un appel à la
population par notre page facebook et
par notre gazette ça pour voir qui
auraient encore d'un des vieilles cours
si rossi ancien et on commence un
travail de repérage et de collègues
lorsque mascarin en 2015 nous propose un
partenariat dans le même but à plusieurs
plans de rebours bon été symboliquement
planté sur le domaine du grand hazier
afin de préserver ce patrimoine le
conseil départemental soit créer
prochainement une nouvelle collection de
reuze bourbeau et roses anciennes au
coeur du jardin botanique de mascarin
hélas cette spécialité de pouvoir mettre
en valeur ou de répertorier ou de sauver
tout ce qui est l'endémique dollars et
il est prévu dans le cadre du
du mascaret de colimaçons de mettre en
place un bout de rose ray comme cela
devait être mis à l'époque être mis en
oeuvre par et de chateauvieux je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le département a toute sa
place dans le conservatoire botanique
aux mascarades de pouvoir remettre en
place un carré de la rose de bois beau
avec toutes ces variétés une roseraie
c'est aussi la réunion c'est aussi mon
âme
voilà on recense aujourd'hui plus de 48
variétés de roses bourbon disséminés
dans le monde entier